did you have a happy childhood you've
talked about how it really wasn't do you
think
um I could absolutely paint a happy
picture of a childhood that would also
be true I think everybody can yes me too
can make you cry with their miserable
childhood and make you envious of your
perfect childhood whilst not lying yes
you know yeah we all have both flavors
running through things and yeah I
attribute most of the whatever
unhappiness was there's you know
different reasons for it but I remember
thinking yeah my anxiety dial is way too
high it took me years to figure that out
that Not only was I anxious but I think
a lot of us were anxious in that house
and uh and then mitigating it because
it's you you can't control your own and
then you can't control anyone else's and
that affects yours right you know one of
the things that
looks and if Dad's ponies didn't come
through that wasn't right that wasn't my
dad but you know it wasn't my dad either
my dad was in a laboratory like with a
cyclotron looking at bacteria but I
loved to tell people that he was a drunk
at the racetrack
just because it's fun for me to paint
that picture
um yeah I wish I was a guy that would
think people think I was cooler if you
were constantly like you showed up today
for the podcast they're like
Conan that he went to the track and he's
he's deep in a hole and we he's he we
can't get him out of there you know he
really up like ooh he's so like
torture he's tortured and I'd come in
and my clothes are all wrinkled and I
have a lot of racing forms coming out of
my pockets and I'm like God dad goddamn
nag you know really screwed me over in
the final stretch do you have a hat I
have a crumpled hat yeah with the
tickets in it
in the 1930s you could just wear a hat
and and write press on a card and stick
it in your hat brim and get into any
crime scene whatsoever hey this is oh
sorry sir you you have a 3x5 card in
your hat okay here's my idea I want to
do something they would totally
infuriate people and I've been obsessed
with this for a while but I want to get
a siren for my car
and
um push like and and every every now and
then if I'm in a rush to get somewhere
and there's a lot of traffic in La I put
the siren on the top of my car
people get out of the way but then
eventually I pull up somewhere and
people notice me just getting out of my
car
right and they're like what the and
I'm like hey man celebrity like it's my
celebrity siren and and it would make
people so mad can you imagine but what
what clear out of the way
celebrity and they're like well not
really it's been a while since you were
on the air yeah and I'm like real
entitled about it just to bypass traffic
yeah everybody pull the side of the road
yeah he's trying to get to koi yeah
no it's never something important it's
always he's meeting David Spade at koi
why do they know that
that goes like move aside I'm meeting
David Spade at koi
we're going to talk about the late 80s
[Applause]
I would just love it people would get so
so mad yeah then you'd be arrested for
impersonating a police officer I never I
never wore the uniform I never
impersonated a but you know what I'm
saying you got a woo-woo on your car so
what that's impersonated I don't think
it's an ambulance one yeah yeah I've
never heard of a lot you can't
impersonate an ambulance yeah
yeah maybe I'm with the forestry service
I'm here to cut dangerous brush you
don't know what my siren's for by the
time they figure it out I'm long gone
they'll never catch me they'll know it's
you though yeah they're supposed to go
to your house or yeah I move around a
lot I'm pretty Shifty no you don't not
at all you're not Shifty at all pretty
much know exactly where you are at any
given time yeah you know you were just
at my house not too long ago yeah we
don't need to get specific but you were
there and uh you add life to any party
yes you do you're always fun people love
to see you it's always a good I mean it
was a good group we had a good group
together yeah yeah we had a good time
and then I made everyone go on around
the room and talk about their favorite
qualities that I have oh
um that didn't go well yeah I have been
around I have been at parties where
people have done that where they you're
supposed to it's lemon's birthday and
everyone's supposed to go around and
talk about what they love about that
person and
um I always think isn't this what Stalin
made people do
you know like now your turn why am I
greatly there you know
I could never do that
to join in did you say something
um at that party at which party that
party where you're supposed to say
something nice like well you just go
pass no I'm not gonna do that I said
something oh that's nice okay yeah it
wasn't that hard felt I'm sure there
were a few little Barbed Jabs in there
of course you know oh I just understood
what you're doing okay
um one thing I really love about Yukon
yeah
whoa that took a while God damn